okay so yeah
okay so let's sort of continue when we
left out so if you recall last time I
outline the sort of meta strategy for
proving lower bounds for algebraic
circuits the first step of this strategy
is to do depth reduction and that's what
we discussed in the last talk and once
you are at a small depth circuit or
formula then you need techniques to
prove lower bounds for such objects okay
and that's sort of the focus for of this
talk and so the answer so so the
question is can we prove lower bounds
for small depth formulas slap circuits
the kinds that we get after a depth
reduction and the answer is yes if you
allow if you put place some sort of
restrictions on your algebraic models of
computation and that's what we're going
to talk about in this stuff and the
techniques here are mostly algebraic
right so you saw the techniques in the
depth reduction thing there is just
divide and conquer algorithm so fairly
common at Oriel whereas here the
techniques will be algebraic typically
based on some sort of linear algebra
matrix rank and so on and we use these
kinds of techniques to prove these
robots all right so this is sort of the
plan for the rest of talk so as I said
I'm not going to prove lower bounds for
general EVPs like formulas whatever I'll
prove low bonds for restricted models
and these multiple be restricted in
different ways so the first model are
considered non commutative AV please
this is again something that Christian
briefly mentioned in the morning and
I'll go through it and we look at
Nissan's lower bound again something the
Christian briefly mentioned but didn't
completely describe okay and then I'm
going to talk about homogeneous Sigma Pi
Sigma formulas yes
the ones we consider all right so that's
a great question so your question is
also if we if we when we do depth
reduction does it preserve all these
criteria and it turns out it preserves
many of them so for example what I said
about algebraic branching programs just
carries through in a non commutative
setting without any changes similar your
homogeneity multi linearity many of
these things are preserved yeah
but it's not always immediate you have
to go through the proof and check okay
right so right so the second thing we'll
do at low bonds for homogeneous Sigma Pi
Sigma formulas again homogeneous I
briefly described the last time but I'll
go through it again and this is a lower
bound due to Nissan and Victor set and
then we will discuss some extensions of
the Nissan magnificent method for
proving the bounds and I'll end with
some open questions so let's start with
the the non commutative lower bound okay
so what are non commutative polynomials
let's just briefly recall right so
suppose I want to compute the way we
sort of motivated algebraic circuits
where computational problems where your
problem is that you want to compute a
multivariate polynomial over elements
that take values in some field okay but
now what if your elements don't take
values in some field but in some some
non commutative domain right so think
for example about 2 by 2 matrices or
things like that
well multiplication is not commutative
but it still makes sense to look at
things like polynomials over that domain
right and if you are looking at things
like this well then a polynomial will be
a linear combination not of commuting
monomials right because matrix product
doesn't commute but your monomials are
going to be more like ordered strings
over your underlying alphabet of
variables right so and now a polynomial
will be a linear combination of such
strings which we add in your combination
of such monomials so that's what a non
commutative polynomial is and I'll
denote non commutative polynomials by
this sort of F bracket
x1 to xn with this angular bracket all
right so here's a simple example of a
non commutative mono polynomial so
suppose I have two variables x and y I
can look at the polynomial which is the
sum of all
length for palindromes let's say were
the alphabet XY and then there are four
lengths for palindrome so you get like a
nice degree for palindrome polynomial
okay so this is sort of a nice feature
about the non commutative setting is
that if you have just two variables in
the commutative setting if you have a
two variable polynomial of degree D then
you can have at most something like d
squared monomials but if you have a two
variable non commutative polynomial of
degree D then you can have two to the d
many monomials okay so it's so sometimes
in the non commutative setting even
looking at polynomials which is two
variables makes a lot of sense it
slightly different from the community of
setting all right so that's a nice
example okay so what do we know with the
non commutative setting and so most of
what I said in the last talk not there's
a small caveat but most of what I said
works just without changes in the non
commutative setting so for example you
can define the same complexity classes
formulas algebraic branching programs
circuits and again you have the same
inclusion Relations formulas are at most
as strong as algebraic branching
programs which are a subclass of
circuits okay and the nice thing about
this is now you can ask your favorite
question in the commutative setting in
the non commutative setting so for
example you can ask does the N by n
permanent have polynomial size non
commutative circuits and this is related
to a commutative circuit is commutative
question in a simple way in particular
the lower bound question here is easier
than the lower bound question in the
commutative side okay so let me just say
a little bit about that but before I
make to make this question precise you
really have to first define what the N
by n permanent means in the non
commutative setting yeah we know what it
means is a commutative polynomial what
is the N by n non commutative permanent
well you can make this precise in any
number of ways you can take your
favorite polynomial for example the
permanent and order every monomial as a
string in some particular way so for
example for the permanent polynomial
have ordered each monomial sort of row
wise and this gives you a non commuting
polynomial is this linear combination of
strings right and now the question is
does this non commutative polynomial
have a small non commutative circuit
and now having a non commutative circuit
for something Israeli for example for
this polynomial is a much stronger thing
than having a commutative circuit right
just on intuitive level having a non
commutative circuit for this polynomial
allows me to compute this polynomial on
non commutative domains like 2x2 matrix
algebra something so in particular given
an algorithm for computing this
permanent over such non commutative
domains I can of course compute compute
them over commutative domains like one
by one matrices so special sub case
right so in particular I'd be able to
compute the the N by n commutative
permanent so in particular having a non
commutative circuit implies that you
have a commutative circuit right so
upper bounds are much harder than the
non commutative setting as a result
lower bounds should be at least in
theory much easier so it should be
formally easier question to prove lower
bounds in a non community setting then
it is to prove in the commutative
setting unfortunately this is still in
theory because these kinds of lower
bounds are still open so in fact the
best lower bounds we have in the non
commutative for non commutative circuits
match the best lower bounds we have a
commutative circuits so we don't really
gain anything at least in the circuit
setting right so if you look at not yeah
absolutely so you have a non commutative
circuits of size 2 to the order n in
fact you can say something more you have
we have non commutative Sigma Pi Sigma
formulas of size 2 to the N for the N by
n permanent right
so right so the circuit question in the
setting is still open but it turns out
that if you set your sights a little bit
lower and instead of doing lower bounds
for circuits you ask for lower bound so
we come orders of computation then we do
have it so for example we know that the
permanent does not have algebraic
branching programs in the non
commutative setting and the permanent by
permanent I mean the non commutative
permanent that I defined the previous
slide
so it's known that it does not have
algebraic branch programs of polynomial
size in particular any non commutative
ABP for the permanent must have at least
2 to the N size so exponential size so I
want to outline a proof of this theorem
I won't prove it for the permanent but
I'll prove it for some other explicit
polynomial and the same ideas result in
the lower bound to the problem alright
so let's begin the lower bound and again
as I said this lower bound follows this
two-step process right the first step is
a depth reduction so now we're going to
do depth reduction for algebraic
branching program because that's the
model for which we want to prove lower
bounds right and I'm not going to use
the full power of the depth reduction
statement I'm just going to use what I
call the basic identity ok and the basic
identity was the following if you have
an algebraic branching program computing
a polynomial of degree D a small
algebraic branches program then it can
be written as a small sum where each
term in the sum is the product of two
polynomials of degree at most D over 2
much smaller and this is sort of the
basic identity we used in doing the net
reduction and it turns out that this is
enough to prove lower bounds for non
commutativity BP's so this is the thing
that I we sort of observed in the last
thing and so a just a slight refinement
of this which is that if I start with an
algebraic branching program that
computes a homogeneous polynomial of
degree T right a homogeneous polynomial
is one that all the monomials are the
same degree so I have a homogeneous
polynomial degree D then I get the same
kind of decomposition but in addition I
have that these polynomials are all
homogeneous they're all homogeneous of
degree D by two and now this version the
homogeneous basic identity is enough for
me to prove lower bounds yeah and the
way we're gonna prove lower bounds is
we're gonna come with an explicit
polynomial for which any
decomposition of this form must have
large signs and that immediately implies
the load now any questions about this
basic strategy before we piece the same
as before yeah it's exactly the same
exactly it's the same so good so the how
so how we going to go about throwing
this know about so the way we're going
to do it is by defining a kind of an
algebraic complexity measure okay so
what we're going to do is take any
polynomial which is homogeneous and
degree D and define a notion of
complexity for it so it's going to be
algebraically defined but it's a number
so a complexity mu of F yeah and this
complexity has the definition that we're
going to get which has some nice
properties the first property is that
it's small for any term in this
summation right so each so you have a
sum of terms each term has small
complexity yeah this the complexity is
sub additive right so if I add together
two terms of small complexity I get
something else or small complexity and
finally I can find an explicit
polynomial such that sorry this should
be the should be mu of if I can find an
explicit polynomial F so if that view of
F is large okay
so we'll define a complexity mu of F for
any polynomial F which has these three
nice properties each term has small
complexity the complexity sabbatical
which means the sum of a small number of
such terms have small complexity but
then we can easily find F so that this
complexity is large which means that any
ABP for such an F must be large so how
do we go about defining this complexity
measure so it's extremely simple it's
basically based on matrix rank
reasonably obvious way okay so let's do
it
so suppose I have a polynomial F
homogeneous of degree T then I can write
it as a linear combination of monomials
so recall that a monomial is just a
string for me so these just strings of
length D over the alphabet x1 to XM so
these strings of length e and each
monomial M has a coefficient which I'm
calling CM the subscript F so what we do
in order to define this notion of
complexity is that we look at a certain
matrix associated with this polynomial
and how this matrix defined so this
matrix is really big the rows and
columns of this matrix are sort of
labeled by monomials of degree D over 2
right so I take every monomial of degree
D over 2 for every string of length D
over 2 over this alphabet of size N and
for every string there's a row in this
matrix and similarly for every mole of
real m2 of degree D over 2 there's a
column okay so it's an n to the D by 2
by an n to the D by 2 size matrix and
now the entry corresponding to row M 1
and the column M 2 is the coefficient of
the product monomial m1 times m2 in my
polynomial F this is the definition
makes sense example here yeah so so
let's take the palindrome polynomial
that we defined a few slides ago right
and so what's the corresponding matrix
here so so it's a polynomial of degree 4
right over to variables so I have a four
by four matrix right the rows are
labeled by monomials of degree two
columns by monomials of degree two and I
put ones or zeros depending on the
coefficients all coefficients are 1 so
zeros here so I put 1 so 0 is depending
on what the coefficient is so you get
some nice 4 by 4 matrix in this case it
turns out to be a permutation matrix oh
so we define this matrix by any
polynomial F and what we do is we define
the complexity of F to be the rank of
this matrix so if we take this big
matrix you look at the rank of this
matrix and that's my notion of
complexity so let's just quickly check
that it satisfies all the nice
properties that we were talking about
the first was that each summand in the
sort of basic identity has small
complexity
and the reason for that is extremely
simple so suppose I take Assam and of
this form F is the product of two
homogeneous polynomials of degree D over
2 now if I look at the coefficient of m1
times m2 in F right this is a non
commutativity really enters the picture
here so I look at the coefficient of m1
times m2 and F well m1 times m2 prop
sort of factors is a product of two
degree D by two monomials in exactly one
way right so you can only [ __ ] to it as
m1 times m2 and not as n 3 times m4 for
some other m3 and m4 right so that means
the coefficient of m1 times m2 in F is
the coefficient of M 1 in P times the
coefficient of M 2 and Q ok and that
immediately implies that the rank of
this matrix is at most 1 which means its
complexity is at most 1 okay right so
this is out of the first property we
wanted we wanted a notion of complexity
so it's at every term in the basic
identity the right-hand side has small
is her small complexity and this is as
small as it gets so the rank is at most
1 so that's really tiny complexity all
right so that's the first property the
second property was that this complexity
measure is sub additive right and one
the complexity of F plus G to be at most
2 complexity of F plus the complexity of
G and this is immediate from the
definition of matrix rank right the way
I have defined this matrix for a given
polynomial F the matrix corresponding to
the sum of two polynomials is the sum of
the corresponding matrices for each
polynomial right so M of F plus G is
just M of F plus M of G so the rank
being a nice sort of sub additive
function then tell you that the notion
of complexity that we have is at MU is
sub additive so the rank of M of F plus
G is at most the rank of M of F it's the
document so the complexity of F of G F
plus G is at most the complexity of F
plus the complexity of G okay so this is
usually subadditivity
values sort of matrix rank to define a
notion of complexity subadditivity
always sort of comes for free because of
this
all right so that's that's about it so
we have ready to prove our lower bound
so so suppose I have some ABP of size s
computing a homogeneous polynomial of
degree D it has this decomposition given
by the basic identity and so what I know
is that the rank of the matrix
corresponding to the abpa is going to be
at most the sum of the ranks
corresponding matrices correspond to
each of these terms right and each of
these terms has rank at most one
so the overall rank adds up at most to
the size of the ABP which is s right so
just think about this I have this
massive matrix it's an N to the D by 2
cross n to the D by 2 matrix so it's a
really big matrix and suppose I have a
polynomial sized ABP I'm saying that
this huge matrix has rank polynomial
which is really really tiny so I'm
saying something very very strong about
polynomials that have small any piece so
that's about it so now yes question so
you you can just define the measure to
be the minimum such that you can write a
in this form in this case it turns out
to be the ring absolutely in this case
actually this is yeah completely right
it's equal to the rank that's right
but this will not always be the case
okay okay good and right so that's it so
that more or less finishes the lower
bounds if all you have to do is now find
an explicit F for which this measure is
not small and then we're done
so that means all we need to do is find
an F so that when we write down this big
matrix for it it has large rank
superpolynomial rank but we can easily
cook up F for which it's in fact full
rank and so that is an exponential load
one right so for example you can stake
the degree D version of the palindrome
polynomial that we're talking about okay
so okay so good great so I just gave to
that maybe after this one right so to
prove a lower bound for explicit F so
what we do is we just take something
like the degree D palindrome polynomial
and exactly analogous to the degree four
case that we wrote down if you write
down the same matrix with a degree D
palindrome polynomial you end up with a
permutation matrix so it's 1 exactly 1 1
in every row and column and otherwise 0
so it's a full rank matrix ok so the
complexity of such an F turns out to be
2 to the D over 2 those have two
variables
it's true the D would slash largest
possible so this immediately implies
that any ABP computing let's say the
palindrome polynomial of degree D must
have size at least two residue
supersorrell for community when no such
measure that exists nothing no the one
those products into something more
religiously right so it's not possible
to say so no as in it depends really on
the complexity of the measure because as
I wish I was saying you can always
define it to be the smallest s for which
it exists it's just that it would not
yeah I don't know if you would get
anywhere with that right so yes you can
always define a measure which is the
smallest s such that you have such a
decomposition and in principle that's
enough to prove lower bounds but well
for the way of this suppose you define
your measure to be the smallest s so
that there is such a decomposition then
the measure of every product is one and
you have all these nice properties it's
just that we don't know how to find an
explicit F for which that measure is
large so the non commutativity was used
in this statement because so what you
are really using here is that the
coefficient of m1 times m2 and L is the
coefficient of M 1 and P times the
coefficient of M 2 in Q and that's
because of non commutativity ok so it's
a rank one matrix because it's non
commutative it's not in general rank one
so so it's due to the D this is time so
question is can you prove a lower bound
of 2 to the D instead of 2 to the D over
2 for a degree D polynomial right so
this is really about so it's really
about when we are measuring a BP size
I'll be talking about vertices or edges
maybe because in terms of vertices this
bound is tight in the sense it's the
largest that it can be for anything
but right if you measure size in terms
of edges then it's conceivable that you
can get 2 to the D but I'm not sure of
such a result should still get like an
in to the D Youville to but then the
question still stands can you come on in
to the DLO about and write and that you
get the same determinant it I think you
can get for every letter you got
something really nice right but that's
going to be much smaller than n to the N
is a boundary term is like 2 to the N
and
you did something encoding the
polynomial is a major constraint there's
no natural way to do this definition
definitely makes sense in the
commutative setting right I can just say
Oh take every monomial degree D over to
think everyone already ready to do it
put the coefficient of the product in
the corresponding entry there will be
multiple things that correspond to the
same yeah same sort of monomial yeah so
it right it's not as neat a definition
by definition still makes sense yeah but
you're right I mean the fact that each
entry corresponds to a unique monomial
is what makes it work in the non
commutative
so like so that's the lower bar so it is
before I continue
so Rahul asked this question about why
doesn't this work for non commutative
circuits and the reason for that is that
the sort of basic identity I wrote down
for non commutative circuits in the last
talk that doesn't quite pan out in the
north I'm sorry I wrote down a basic
argument basic identity for commutative
circuits that doesn't quite pan out in a
non commutative setting in fact in the
non commutative setting there is no
depth reduction for circuits there is a
depth direction for a BP is a deflection
for formulas but for circuits it breaks
down yeah in fact the palindrome
polynomial here it actually has a non
commutative circuit but nothing of small
depth
Pollak any other questions
all right so now let's go back to the
commutative setting so all right so so
what we want to do is sort of port these
kinds of bounds to commutative setting
okay and one at least one strategy might
be to just look at the basic identity
and again try this kind of argument we
don't know how to make it work okay but
you can sort of go further this is not
the only sort of depth reduction
statement we proved the last time we
proved others right and so if you
briefly if you recall I said that we can
reduce to depth for by blowing up the
size a little bit okay and just recall
the statement of that and try to
motivate what comes next so what we
showed in the last hour was that if you
start with an AVP which computes a
circuit of sizes and a polynomial degree
D it's not just that you can write it
down as a sum as a small sum of pairs
products of pairs of polynomials you can
also write it down as a small sum as a
product of many more than a just a pair
for numbers many many polynomials each
of small degree you can do this and you
can do it in a way where the blow up is
not too much so I don't want to get into
what these numbers were from the last
hour but this S Prime was not much much
larger than s it was super polynomial
but it was not like a trivial blow up
the result of this kind of depth
reduction was that if you can prove
non-trivial lower bounds for these kinds
of objects so in particular if you can
show that a polynomial has the property
that any such decomposition as a sum of
many many products of many many small
degree polynomials must be large then in
fact you've shown a lower bound for a
BP's so this is seems at least in
Hannity an easier model to deal with
than this one right because this is just
a product of two polynomials these are
products of many polynomials of small
degree you can always compute a
converter polynomial a product of many
polynomials into product of two
polynomials because you just break them
into two buckets but it's not clear how
to go the other way so this is
definitely a stronger become
position right and you can hope to use
this in order to prove lower bounds kbps
so can we right and that's the question
so can we prove lower bounds okay so we
don't know how to use the basic identity
to prove your balance can we use this
lightly souped up version of the basic
identity to prove lower bounds
okay can we prove lower bounds for these
kinds of formulas and in particular can
we prove strong enough lower bounds that
will allow us to infer lower bounds on
generality please and so this is what
sort of what's going to motivate what I
talk about next but the sort of the
short answer is we can't prove lower
bounds for these kinds of objects but
the kinds of lower bounds we prove fall
exactly short of proving superpolynomial
lower bounds for generally Big B's okay
so we can prove something but not to the
extent that we can prove super
polynomial a bit below so it actually
falls just short so I hope that made
sense okay
okay so so let's go ahead with proving
lower bounds for homogeneous Sigma Pi
Sigma Pi formulas okay and it's sort of
actually dealing with that more
complicated model I'll actually deal
with an even I'll prepare two low bonds
an even simpler model which are
homogeneous Sigma Pi Sigma formulas so
what are these so just recall that a
formula is said to be Sigma Pi Sigma if
it's a sum of product of linear
functions right that's what a Sigma Pi
Sigma formula is and I'm only going to
deal with homogeneous Sigma Pi Sigma
formulas so homogeneous Sigma Pi Sigma
formulas essentially Sigma Pi Sigma
formulas that never compute polynomials
of degree larger than necessary right so
if I'm computing a polynomial of degree
D I'm going to be looking at a sum of
terms each of which computes a
polynomial of degree D so it's going to
be a product of at most D linear
functions okay that's what that's how I
define a homogeneous Sigma Pi Sigma so
even weaker model that sort of
interesting and this is related to what
Christian was speaking about in the
morning
where instead of allowing these products
to involve different linear polynomials
you just forced them to be the power of
a same the same linear polynomial right
so it's just a sum of powers of a linear
polynomial okay and I'll call this the
Sigma I'll call this a Sigma power Sigma
formula okay so it's denoted in this
funny way with a sort of a wedge between
two Sigma's so Sigma power Sigma formula
is just the sum of powers of linear
polynomials okay okay and so just to
connect up with what Christian was
saying in the morning the smallest s
says that some polynomial has a
description of this form is the Waring
rank of that polynomial so the
complexity in this model is closely
related to worrying luck
okay so just to recall we want to prove
lower bonds are Sigma Pi Sigma Pi
formulas but instead I'm going to prove
lower bounds for these weaker objects
and then tell you a little bit about how
to do the other thing all right so
there's an interesting thing though when
you look at this Sigma power Sigma
formulas is that it's not clear that
every polynomial has such a
representation right so usually when we
do complex T theory we dealing with
complete ones of computation and then
you want to prove lower bounds for some
explicit polynomial but it's not even
clear that every polynomial can be
written as a sum of powers of linear
functions so for example the polynomial
X 1 X 2 it's not clear that it can be
written as a sum of powers of linear
functions but in fact it can and this
was explicitly pointed out in this
result of spelke from 2001 that any
polynomial has a sigma power sigma
formula of exponential signs so the
upper bounds are given an exponential
but in principle every polynomial can be
computed this way and the way to prove
this is where this thing called Fisher's
identity that question pointed out in
the morning questions about this
okay so we want to prove lower bounds
for Sigma Pi Sigma and Sigma power Sigma
formulas so how do we go about doing it
right and again the idea is the same
right so here there is no really depth
reduction because the depth is already
small so there's no depth reduction so
it's just the second step that we have
to do okay and what's the second step
again we define this complexity measure
for polynomials right and you want to do
it in a way so that the complexity of
each term in this sum is small and the
complexity is sub additive okay and
finally we will find the polynomial for
which the complexity is large and that
will give us the low power so what's the
complexity in this case it turns out to
be a rank again the rank of a matrix and
the rank of the so-called partial
derivative matrix which I'll define on
the next slide okay so it so misaeng
victus and defined this very nice notion
of a partial derivative matrix there's a
rank of the partial derivative matrix
will be the right complexity measure to
use in the setting and so this is a
pretty important technique in algebraic
complexity because sort of been built
upon and it's been used in many
different ways to prove lower bounds so
something it's also known that nice and
big this is not the first people to
define this so Silvestre back in 1851
apparently looked at some version of
this so it's known from slightly
sometime before but okay so we look at
the nice on with the same definition all
right so just to motivate this
definition of a partial derivative
matrix right let's go back to nissan's
measure from the last the
non-commutative refer back and sort of
derive sort of see why partial
derivatives might be useful in this
context so if you recall we had this
sort of matrix definition for the
complexity of a non commutative
polynomial and this how it worked for
example for the palindrome polynomial
degree four okay so suppose we want to
define an analogue this sort of analogue
this complexity measure for commutative
polynomials how would I go about doing
it one way to do it is to see what this
measure means on some related
commutative polynomial and sort of get
intuition from that so how would we
think of f of X Y this palindrome
polynomial as a commutative polynomial
so how do you think of it well one way
is to simply let all the variables
commute that's the obvious way
but when you're doing that you're losing
information right you're losing
information about where the positions of
various variables so it's more losing
information if you are allowing
variables to come here so an alternate
nicer thing to do is to sort of tag
every variable with the position that it
appears in okay so in a non computing
monomial a monomial is a string so a
variable appearing in the monomial
carries two bits of in two kinds of
information the variable itself and the
position that it appears in and if you
sort of tagged the variable with this
position and then you allow things to
commute you really are preserving all
the information in the polynomial okay
so a natural thing to do is maybe look
at the following polynomial so you just
take the same thing but now you make
four copies of the X variables X 1 2 X 4
and 4 copies the Y variables Y 1 2 y 4
and now instead of looking at x times x
times X times X you look at X 1 times X
2 times X 3 times X for the content
being that you have an X at position 1
times an X at position 2 etcetera
etcetera and now if you think of this as
a commutative polynomial is a commuting
polynomial you've not really lost any
information it's the you can sort of
read off the non commutative polynomials
from it so it's a nice way of sort of
translating from the non commutative the
commutative setting and the good thing
about looking at things this way is that
partial derivatives very naturally start
appearing when you look at me sons
measure okay
so for example if I look at the partial
derivative of this polynomial
corresponding the variables x1 and x2
right so there's some basic calculus
will tell you that the partial
derivative correspond to x1 mix 2 is
essentially the sum of all those terms
that contain x1 and x2 right so that's
I'm writing it sort of in a verbose way
but it's really 1 it's just X 3 times X
4 but I'm writing as 1 times X 3 X 4
plus 0 times X 3 y 4 plus other things
ok so this is exactly the first row of
my matrix right so one way of sort of
interpreting the matrix the coefficient
matrix that we use to define this and
measure is that the rows of this matrix
are just partial derivatives of this
polynomial corresponding to variables
that appear in positions 1 and 2
and so this is a so it's kind of natural
to see we're partial derivatives appear
here and it's sort of this kind of idea
we are trying to lift two general
polynomials in the commutative setting
so it's some vague intuition it's not
very precise but I hope this gives you
some feeling for why partial derivatives
are necessary and important there's also
some sort of geometric intuition but I
don't have it so okay so all right so
let's go ahead and define this partial
derivative measure okay so now I'm given
a polynomial F in x1 to xn it's a
commuting polynomial and I want to
define my complexity of this polynomial
and in order to do this again I'm going
to define this big matrix and okay and
now the rows of my matrix are going to
be partial derivatives of my polynomial
okay so I take my polynomial F and I
look at all Kait order partial
derivatives of s yeah for some case so K
is going to be a parameter that we'll
choose to our advantage so k fix some K
and take all partial derivatives of
order K okay so here I am taking partial
derivatives with respect to distinct
variables doesn't have to be that way
but just for simplicity let's take
distinct variables here so I take all
partial derivatives of F with respect to
K distinct variables and that gives me a
set of polynomials right I get a large
set of polynomials so for every possible
set of K variables I get a polynomial
right and now I write down this giant
matrix where the rows of this matrix are
labeled by K sets of variables the sets
of variables with respect to which I
take the partial derivative and the row
corresponding to x1 to XK is the
polynomial which is obtained by taking
derivative with respect to x1 to XK
right I take this polynomial I write it
down as a list of coefficients right so
suppose I start with a degree D
polynomial this would be a degree D
minus K polynomial so it has one
coefficient for every monomial of degree
at most D minus K so I write down this
list of coefficients and that gives me
if I when I write it down for the whole
thing that gives me the partial
derivative matrix
so the definition is clear
and finally the complexity of my
polynomial is you gain the rank of this
partial derivative so you just go
through a small example right so yeah
small thing is that I can also write
this as so I can write this as the rank
of the matrix but I can also write it as
the dimension of the span of the rows
that's sort of a nice short form for it
and will be useful all right so let's
just do a small example so for example
let's say your polynomial was the very
simple polynomial which is just the
product of all the variables x1 to xn
right so now what's the partial
derivative matrix well when I take
derivative with respect to some K
variables may be x i1 through excit
then what I'm going to do is essentially
divide by those variables right so what
I'm going to be left with is the product
of the remaining variables is the
remaining variable so if I add my take
derivative of respect to X I 1 - exactly
I get product of all those exchange
where J does not lie in the set I want -
ok right so now every row of this matrix
is going to have a single one and it's
going to be entirely zero otherwise
right and each row has a 1 in a
different position
because from the derivative you can
easily sort of read off the variables
that you derived with respect to right
so each row has a single one and
different rows have ones in different
positions so this is again going to be a
full rank matrix the rows are going to
be all linearly independent so may a
full row rank matrix yeah so the rank of
this polynomial is going to be n choose
K which is the number of rows in this
matrix
okay
okay so that's a simple example and now
but you can do it for other things okay
so that's it so that's how complexity
measure and now let's use it to prove
lower bounds again
okay so again our model of computation
is that we're taking sums of powers of
linear functions and now the we want to
prove that our complexity measure has
the right properties right the
properties we want to prove are that
each term in this sum has small
complexity and that the complexity
measure is sub additive right sub
additive subadditivity again follows
from the fact that this is a rank
measure and rank a sub additive so
there's nothing to prove there the
non-trivial thing to prove here is that
each term in this expansion has small
complexity and that's again something
very very easy to prove so I claim that
each power of a linear function has
complexity at most one and that's just
elementary calculus you think about it
so if you take the tail order derivative
of a linear polynomial raised to the
power D right doesn't matter which
variables you take the derivative with
respect to you're going to get the same
thing up to a constant right so every
time you derive with respect to a
variable sort of shape of a linear
function you get a new constant so in
general you get a product of these
constants times a lower power of the
same linear genius right no it doesn't
need to be right I mean I mean what you
meant to do I mean even if it's not it's
true I think
so I mean you can't derive the constant
in any case yeah okay so so the
important thing is that every derivative
right so the derivative they've come I
have n choose K distinct derivatives but
all these derivatives are scalar
multiples of the same thing right which
means that all the rows in my matrix are
the same a peculiar multiplication which
means that this matrix has rank one
right so this matrix has a rank it goes
one and then by subadditivity my formula
which is a sum of at most s such terms
as a rank at most s so that's the sort
of nice property we have from this
complexity right here okay great and so
now in order to prove a lower bound all
we have to do is find some explicit
polynomial which has large measure and
this is something we've already done
right so we we said take the monomial X
1 to xn the rank this the partial
derivative matrix of this monomial has
all distinct rows right on his distinct
rose linearly independent rows and
therefore its rank is something that n
choose K the number of rows in this
matrix and therefore what this means is
that any sort of decomposition of the
monomial of the form this to the power
is going to have size at least n choose
K yes I just want to make a point right
there guys that Christians talk in the
morning in terms of board are wearing
rank so ones critically strong version
of the question that yes this morning is
the converse to the first implication
they say that if F has small rank under
this measure is it true that F has a
small sum of linear powers summer I was
looking for
I ain't just in the sense that like that
might be more concrete than the general
order rate setting hey but didn t ask
but there's not a characterization of
whether this has small parcel coverage
so it's like a question you know maybe s
and the left hand side is a little bit
larger than s on the right hand side
thank
you cannot succeed develop in this
formula it should be exponential right
because you can take K to be a number to
look exactly so right so now K is a
parameter that we can choose as we want
and so we can take K equals n over 2
that gives us the best bound and so
we'll get that any for any such
decomposition for the minami almost have
size at least n choose n over 2 almost 2
to the N and 2 to the N is roughly the
right answer in fact 2 to the N is the
right answer so Christian gave he wrote
down this identity in the morning they
recalled Fisher's identity and that
shows that in fact the monomial X 1 to X
n does have such a decomposition with 2
to the n minus 1 terms and this gives an
almost matching lower bound
can you improve the lower bond yeah so I
think it's known that due to the N minus
one is tight but not yr this technique
okay so alright so that's it for Sigma
power Sigma formulas let me also tell
you a little bit about Sigma Pi Sigma
formulas which is sort of a stronger
model of computation and it turns out
that more or less the same idea is
proved lower bounds even here okay
so again our power complexity measure is
going to be the same thing we're just
going to take partial derivative
matrices with respect to K partial
derivatives okay but this time the
computations are a little bit different
okay so previously we had that the each
term has complex T at most one this time
the complexity is not one but it's a not
very large number okay it turns out to
be something like they choose K and now
be choose T might be pretty large but
you notice that it has no dependence on
n so if you think of B and K as somewhat
smaller than n this is much smaller than
n choose K which is the maximum rank of
this matrix so you can do this and then
again you can show that by subadditivity
that the complexity of this entire
formula is at most s times T choose K
okay and you can use this now to derive
explicit lower bounds for Sigma Pi Sigma
homogeneous formulas okay and in order
to do that you'll have to come up with
some polynomial for which this
complexity is again very large right we
did it for the monomial of degree n but
now I want a polynomial of degree D for
which this is very large so it's going
to be a slightly different question and
you can do this right so here's a simple
polynomial for which this can be done so
this is the so-called elementary
symmetric polynomial of degree D so it's
the polynomial where you sum all terms
of degree D that contain at most one
occurrence of every variable so you sum
all monomials of degree D that contain
at most one occurrence variable so it's
called the elementary symmetric
polynomial of degree T and it's a
partial derivative matrix is very easy
to analyze because well what's it going
to look like right so when you take
derivative you take derivatives of this
polynomial with respect to K variables
what's going to happen is that all the
terms that contain all these K variables
are going to survive and I'm going to be
divided by these K variables and all the
terms that don't contain any of these
variables are sort of going to become 0
okay so you're going to end up with
of degree D minus K and what that the
polynomials going to correspond to is
essentially the sum of all monomials of
degree D minus K that don't intersect
with the set of variables that you took
the derivative with respect to so if you
took the derivative the respect to x1
will be these sets should not contain X
1 and so on so what you're going to get
this matrix what it's going to look like
this it's going to be a 0 1 matrix the
rows of this matrix are indexed by sets
of size K which are the sets of
variables with respect to which you took
a derivative the columns are live or
index a subsets of size D minus K and
you're going to have a 1 if and only if
the corresponding sets are disjoint from
each other
so this matrix actually appears quite a
bit in combinatorics and also theory CS
and other places so the so-called
disjointness matrix and the rank of this
matrix has been investigated by a lot of
people and it's known that for example
if you're working with characteristic 0
and K is suitably related to D then this
matrix is indeed full rank and so you
can just plug this fact in and derive
the law
so any questions at all about Sigma Pi
Sigma lower bounds
okay so great so okay so let's finally
get to so it's the same B argument is
the same you still get the same lower
bound
I really didn't use the fact that the
powers were all D in that setting but I
do use it here here I need that the
degrees are at masti but in the previous
the Sigma power Sigma lower bound the
exponents could really be arbitrary that
matter
all right so all right so what have we
done right so I wanted to prove lower
bounds for general commutative every
piece I said okay proving your bounds
for general commutative every piece
reduces to proving your bounds for Sigma
Pi Sigma Pi formulas with some nice
restrictions I said okay before we do
that maybe we should do Sigma Pi Sigma
formulas first and now we have done that
so now we should probably go back to
Sigma Pi Sigma Pi and see what can be
done and it turns out so this is the
question so suppose I want to prove our
bounds not for Sigma Pi Sigma but
homogeneous Sigma Pi Sigma Pi what can I
do it turns out that the partial
derivative method no longer works okay
so that's the first thing and even if
you extend the model a little bit from
sums of products of linear functions to
sums of products of quadratics already
the partial derivative method breaks
down and you cannot prove lower bounds
and this was a sticking point for a
while until sort of a breakthrough
result by Kayal in 2012 very you've
mented the method of partial derivatives
and invented the super shifted partial
derivative a method throwing your bounds
and it turns out that these this
technique can actually we use to prove
lower bounds for Sigma Pi Sigma Pi okay
so let me just I'm not going to do the
computation in this case because gets
very hairy but I'll just tell you what
the complexity measure hey curious and
tell you what bounds we can prove and
then I'm one less now all right
so in the partial derivative matrix all
we do is we look at the space of partial
derivatives and we try to measure its
rank now what we do is that we augment
this space a little bit in the sense
that we start with the space of partial
derivatives but we sort of shift them by
multiplying them with monomials of some
degree okay so you take your partial
derivatives and you multiply them with
monomials of degree at most else okay
and here L is some parameter okay so
you're looking at every partial
derivative you can every monomial of
degree at most and you multiplying them
together and getting a large finite set
of polynomials and this is these are
going to be the rows of your matrix okay
ultimately you can just define the
complexity of my fault your polynomial
to be the dimension of the span of
the settlement does it make sense right
so if I take L equals zero and I don't
shift by anything then I get the partial
derivative measure but for larger L I
get a more a different object and
there's the thing that we study okay
and again subadditivity is easy but it's
non-trivial to prove that the complexity
of each term is small and the definition
of what is small and etcetera gets a
little technically complicated oh so but
let me just give you a little bit of
intuition for why is such a thing might
be useful okay so at least that this has
some sort of content otherwise it just
looks like a trick so it turns out that
this the space of shifted partial
derivatives with this particular space
has some sort of at least it measures
something that's algebraically nice okay
and what is that thing so just recall
that if I have a collection of
polynomials right if I were collection
of polynomials I can talk about the idea
generated by those polynomials right and
the idea generated by those polynomials
so this is just from algebra so suppose
I have I don't know F 1 F 2 in F X 1 2 X
n the idea generated by F 1 and F 2 this
is all those polynomials that can be
written as f 1 times P 1 plus F 2 times
P 2 where P 1 and P 2 are arbitrary
polynomials so that's the idea generated
by a funny - and now this of course can
be written as a linear combination every
polynomial is a linear combination of
monomial so this can be written as a
linear combination of things like F 1
times a monomial
and similarly in the second term can be
written as a linear combination of f2
times a monomial okay so the ideal
generated by f1 and f2 is in the span of
the shifts of f1 and f2 right because f1
times M is exactly what you get when you
shift F 1 similarly shift F 2 so in
general the ideal generated by the kate
order partial derivatives of F is
exactly things which are in the span of
all shifts of the kate order partial
derivatives with no bound on the degrees
of these shifts so the ideal is this
infinite dimensional vector space is
spanned by this infinite set of vectors
with no bound on the degrees of that and
now what we are trying to do is sort of
measure the size of this ideal size of
this ideal has some sort of algebraic
contain some some geometric content
etcetera we're trying to measure the
size of this ideal but how do we measure
the size of an infinite dimensional
vector space well I don't know any way
to do it so what we do is we sort of
take slices of this vector space and we
measure the dimension of that and that's
what we do when we sort of restrict the
degrees of these monomials okay so sort
of what we are trying to do is measure
the size of this idea and the size of
this ideal has something to do some sort
of capture some nice algebraic sliced
geometric property and that's what we're
trying to do and that's the motivation
behind defining things okay and okay so
now you can do this and you can prove
interesting results so I don't have much
time so I'll just quickly breeze through
to but I won't spend too much time so
the first thing is that the bound that
we proved for sums of powers of linear
functions we can recover a similar bound
for sums of powers of higher degree
polynomials so not just sums of powers
of linear function but sums of pipes of
higher degree polynomials so that's
something we can prove this way sort of
more relevantly to algebraic circuit
complexity what we can show is that we
can prove lower bounds for homogeneous
Sigma Pi Sigma Pi formulas and we can
prove pretty good lower bounds we can
prove lower bounds of the form n to the
square root D okay for a degree D
polynomial in something like n variables
okay so this is very very good the only
thing is that to prove superpolynomial
lower bounds
one end to some super constant time
square root B so if I could improve this
end to the root B to end two though I
don't know Rudy times log n or n to the
root D times log star n I'd get super
polynomial oh bonds we don't know how to
do that but we know how to match this n
to the root D and this is not very
surprising because the polynomial for
which we prove the lower bound is
actually a polynomial that has a small
circuit ok so if we cannot prove that
that this polynomial does not have small
circuits and so this polynomial is is
actually a nice poem is called it's
essentially the polynomial that's
complete for algebraic branching
programs so so-called ight rated matrix
multiplication polynomial so it's just a
product of a bunch of matrices where all
the entries are distinct variables so
what this means is the kind of depth
reduction results we've shown in
reducing to depth for they're sort of
tight you cannot push them any further
and so we have to improve the lower
bound in order to prove it oh so I think
that's all I wanted to say about shift a
partial derivatives so have five minutes
left so let me just go through some open
questions and these open questions model
is related to what I spoke about today
there are many others so one very sort
of nice question which should be
attackable but I don't know why we don't
have problems on it is proving lower
bounds for noncommutative VP okay as I
said for noncommutative VBP for
branching programs we have exponential
lower bounds we have a lot of
understanding and there are also larger
classes inside VP for which we have
lower bounds but for some reason we are
not able to prove lower bounds the VP
and again you could try to follow the
sort of two-step procedure here and it
turns out that in some sense the first
step has already been done so there's
work of rubbish we listen and Yahoo they
are from 2010 who reduce this question
to a kind of a commutative low depth
question okay so I'm not written the
exact question down here but it's a very
nice problem called the sum of squares
problem it's nothing to do with the
other sum of squares in optimization
it's a difference of squares so it's a
very nice problem or sum of squares
identities
and proving lower bounds for that low
depth problem will imply exponential
lower bounds procedure potentially for
noncommutative circuits okay and as I
said it's very sad that we don't have
any better lower bounds for non
commutative circuits than we have for
commutative circuits okay so it's a very
sad state of affairs and this was you
sort of there was some explanation given
for this recently by casino in puggly
odd so a little bit and Mahalo is a very
recent paper who where they show that
even slightly non-trivial circuit lower
bounds right so let's say I don't know
what into the 1.5 circuit lower bounds
something like that bill in the non
commutative setting you make Li imply
very very strong circuit compounds okay
so you can interpret this either
positively or negatively I would
interpret it positively so now try to
prove into the 1.5 circuit lower bounds
and then we get something very nice so
that's one question not a very nice
question that sort of we don't know how
to answer is whether we can separate
these complexity classes in the non
commutative world we define formulas non
commutative formulas non-committed
Reggie breakdancing programs it's known
that one caste contained inside the
other but we don't know if this
containment is strict okay so can you
show that can you show a separation
between the power of algebraic branching
programs and the power of algebraic
formulas in the non commutative setting
we expect this kind of separation to be
true even in the commutative setting but
non commutative setting is a sort of a
nice starting point and this problem has
actually a very nice formulation in
terms of polynomials is just showing
that any formula for multiplying be many
n by n matrices where DS let's say n
must have super polynomial size okay so
it's just proving a lower bound for I
treated matrix multiplication it's a
very very natural question sort of it
also reduces a nice small depth question
which you probably won't talk about but
it's kind of the non commutative
algebraic analog of separating NL and NC
1 yeah so if you believe NL is different
from NC 1 maybe this is the right place
to start
all right so another problem that's of a
good
maybe place to make progress is lower
bounds for in homogeneous Sigma Pi Sigma
formulas so we spoke about homogeneous
Sigma Pi Sigma formulas which are Sigma
Pi Sigma formulas where every term has
degree bounded by the degree of the
final polynomial but now you can ask
about formulas where intermediate terms
can compute very high degree polynomials
right so it's just a sum of products of
linear functions but these individual
products can be really really big and
now can somehow things cancel out and
you compute a small degree polynomial a
nice way and potentially this can
compute very very difficult polynomials
so we have next to no lower bounds here
the best lower bound we have is a recent
result of Chi al-safa and tavernas where
we get near cubic lower bounds for this
model and it would be nice to improve
this and I think I have one more
question and this sort of a meta
complexity question in algebraic
complexity and it's the general question
of whether the kinds of techniques that
I spoke about and more general
techniques in algebraic complexity can
they prove super polynomial lower bounds
at all right so in the setting of
boolean circuits we have natural proofs
and we have many other things that sort
of barriers to what they can accomplish
and we say fee there has been sort of
analogous work in the algebraic setting
so the kinds of rank based techniques
that I spoke about today for proving
lower bounds in the second half of my
talk it's known that these cannot prove
all the things we might want to prove so
for example about worrying rank it's
known that these rank based techniques
might not yield the best possible lower
bounds okay and there are statements
like this it's a recent work of a
flamenco Garg Oliveira and witnessin
which proves this and they've built
other results about algebraic versions
of natural preusse barriers and it will
be nice to sort of strengthen these try
to understand whether these rule-out
lower bounds for intermediate models of
computation exactly where the barrier is
learning okay so that's all about I have
to say thank you
[Applause]
no questions
[Music]
[Applause]